hello everyone i'm alana welcome to my
channel where today i
have something pretty cool to show you
guys
it's an xbox series x my gosh
it's really here i'm excited to see it
um this is obviously such a weird
console launch because you know we
haven't
seen these things in person in stores
and display cases
at events at the xbox one launch i was
working for xbox at the time i actually
worked for them
and i remember the launch party they had
um master chief deliver
the first xbox one uh technically we
were second cause australian time zone
comes after new zealand
new zealand did this thing with like a
shark tank it was crazy but they had
master chief deliver it
in a speed boat under the sydney harbour
bridge it was very cool
this xbox launch i am alone in my very
warm studio apartment but i am
excited all the same because new
hardware
means uh better performing video games
shorter loading screens
all that good stuff all right i just cut
the tape but i guess i'll show you guys
the whole box first so obviously
this is the front aside number one it
sets
4k 120 frames per second 8k hdr
xbox velocity architecture one terabyte
ssd
vrr which is a variable refresh rate a
4k blu-ray
includes an ultra high-speed hdmi
wireless networking capability a
wireless controller and the xbox series
x console
i do also want to note
they did also send me this if i didn't
mention microsoft sent me this full
disclosure
this is going to be one of the
proprietary uh storage drives let's just
open this first shall we oh it's already
open
see how small it is oh oh it's way
smaller than i expected
oh your little ceo is actually tiny look
at it
that's so small i don't know why i
thought it was bigger than this
there you go that'll slot into the back
of my console put those back over there
the back of it which does make me i have
i have a question about this so
obviously
got your big old master chief i wonder
if they designed and made these boxes
when they thought halo infinite was
still a launch title
because that's a big master chief and a
big marketing thing for a game that
we don't even have a release date for
feels like it would be a weird thing to
do if that weren't the case
um this side just totally blank so
let's open her up anyone who's new here
um
my unboxings are always sort of bad
because as i said
you know studio apartment by myself
i don't have much space okay i'm opening
it it's happening i'm opening
it up oh this is ooh ooh this is
interesting
okay why is this part heavy
many questions this one i got first
just just set up stuff yeah this is just
a basic
setup how-to i don't need instructions
who are you kidding i'm going to show
you what this box looks like
that's the console there is also this
box that was in the um
the lid pot so let's open this up first
all right we have a power cable we have
an ultra high speed hdmi cable you can
tell
because of the flaps
and i guess we have
the xbox series x controller
it feels more textured
which i love that's what i love my
elites for
i like this d-pad feels a little bit
sturdier
generally like ergonomically
feels the same i feel like something
about the buttons feel a little more
sturdy in a strange way
so far i like it i don't know that i
would use this over using an elite uh
we'll have to find out
i doubt it oh it's very good all right
i'll put that over here for now
okay let's keep going
how big are you big thick boy i know
you're pretty sizable
that's what she said before you do it in
the comments i did it first sucker
okay yeah you big you you big stop it
stop it
here we go here it is oh my gosh
it is um bigger than my hand span so
actually a little bit hard to hold
oh oh you're chunky oh can you imagine
if i dropped it
just waiting for my neighbor to finish
talking outside
he's very noisy do you think he knows
what i have in my lap
buddy we got [ __ ] to do
all right here we go you guys the xbox
series x
[Music]
it's large it's quite large it's the
size of my forearm
really further than just the size of my
forearm
for scale i'm five foot ten this thing's
pretty big
i've already got my grubby fingerprints
all over it but obviously this can be a
disk drive this is your power
uh that's just give you some angles
shall we
another side that says xbox good
branding here's the little thing on the
bottom to stand on
and here's your top which i actually
really like the way that looks to the
side that's actually
very neat i feel like the photos i've
seen so far haven't shown that up very
well
that's cool i like it so yeah
here it is big boy uh i will have an
entirely separate video of me you know
setting it up turning it on booting it
up all that good stuff so
this is really just the unboxing which
um
it's pretty quick i wonder if there's
something i can grab the scale here i do
have an xbox one down here
this is my one of a kind mike's hot a
lemonade dude that's
sweet xbox one x all right we hold these
two next to each other
that's a big boy they're uh about the
same height i guess the xbox one x is a
tiny bit taller but
a lot wider that's for sure
and yeah that's pretty much it like the
packaging was all very sleek and neat
and tidy and
didn't come with uh anything else worth
noting
or literally anything else at all i feel
like this is the first thing that i've
gotten from xbox and aegis that doesn't
have game pass
for free in it too here it is
next up i get to set it up very excited
welcome i look forward to playing
you know very speedy video games on you
you big
fridge of a thing